die werkstatt am dienstag herzlich
willkommen zu unserem corona kompakt
gleiche zu gast unsere rechts expertin
sarah tacke und weiter keine entwarnung
vom robert-koch-institut experten gehen
von steigenden zahlen der todesfälle
durch corona aus unser
nachrichtenüberblick beginnt auf der
autobahn wo inzwischen hunderte trucker
auf rastplätzen fest sitzen
es sieht aus wie ein entspannter
grillabend doch die stimmung unter den
truckern ist äußerst angespannt
die lkw-fahrer müssen liefern aber in
ihren pausen stehen sie immer noch vor
vielen verschlossenen sanitären anlagen
und rasthöfen autohof fast keine
toiletten vernünftig das ist alles
abgeschlossen essen kannst du auch nicht
mehr gehen mitnehmen kannst du nur noch
freiheit gegrenzt was soll ich dazu
sagen
schlimme situation auf jeden fall für
alle beteiligen fahrern und da ist noch
die katastrophale auftragslage denn
transporte für nicht systemrelevante
waren wurden heruntergefahren
viele lkw fahrer stehen ohne arbeit da
das betrifft vor allem die fahrer aus
osteuropa
ich bin etwa seit vier wochen in
deutschland unterwegs
ich stehe derzeit leer an der rastanlage
und warte wie die meisten meiner
kollegen auf fracht ich weiß nicht was
mich danach erwartet den lkw fahrern
geht es nicht gut
das schlimmste für alle aber ist keiner
weiß wie es weitergeht und vor allem
wann die anzahl der neu übermittelten
fälle ist etwas geringer
von einer entspannung kann aber noch
nicht ausgegangen werden schwankungen
sind immer möglich das budget zu
beachten dass johns hopkins institut
vermeldet heute 103 1717 infizierte und
36.000 81 genesene
in münchen steht seit ende märz ein food
truck der die obdachlosen mit essen
versorgt nachdem die bahnhofsmission und
andere einrichtungen schließen mussten
springt eine cateringfirma spontan ein
da machen wir wir haben die herren die
ministerin dazu die butter statt der
food truck hat an der ecke zwischen
luisenstraße und elisenstraße position
bezogen und wird zweimal täglich essen
ausgeben eltern im home-office vor drei
jahren ging das viral diese live schalte
für die bbc wurde 2017 der hit im
internet südkorea experte robert kelly
gibt gerade ein interview als seine
kinder rein platzen
nun zeigte sich die zweitberühmteste
kelly family wieder mit den kindern im
home-office diesmal aber freiwillig die
kinder sprühen vor energie und gehen
täglich die wände hoch erzählt er
also alles völlig normal bei mir ist
jetzt sagte die leiterin der abteilung
recht und justiz im zdf sarah ich gehöre
auch dazu viele haben jetzt tickets für
großveranstaltungen für konzerte zum
beispiel und die sind teilweise noch
nicht abgesagt worden was passiert damit
kann ich mein geld zurück muss darauf
warten dass sie abgesagt werden erst
dann hat man anspruch darauf auch sein
geld zurückzubekommen die regel ist ganz
einfach wenn ein konzert oder ein
fußballspiel oder eine
theaterveranstaltung unmöglich ist also
nicht stattfinden kann gegen korona habe
ich grundsätzlich ein anspruch mein geld
zurück zu bekommen
aber morgen ganz aktuell will die
bundesregierung genau daran will das
gesetzbuch das bürgerliche gesetzbuch
ändern und veranlassen dass eben
konzertveranstalter musikveranstalter
sich reihenweise pleite gehen weil die
menschen jetzt ihr geld zurückholen
sondern sagen die man kriegt jetzt in
zukunft nicht mehr sein geld zurück
sondern stattdessen gutscheine
das ist das was man dann in der hand
haben wird das soll morgen ganz aktuell
geändert werden und dann gibt es auch
noch gutscheine und dann würde es also
es muss noch durch den bundestag dann
aber dann wird es sehr wahrscheinlich
nur noch gutscheine geben indes klar
danke sehr attacke und sie werden gleich
hier noch weitere zuschauer fragen
beantworten
die welt hofft dass bald ein impfstoff
gegen kuwait 19 gefunden wird aber das
wird wohl noch eine ganze weile dauern
experten haben aber die hoffnung
zumindest ein wirksames medikament
gefunden zu haben
mit dem die kranken gang behandelt
werden können das münchner klinikum
rechts der isar
derzeit werden hier 77 corona patienten
behandelt knapp 30 davon auf der
intensivstation
die klinik sieht sich gut gerüstet ist
doch deshalb teil einer weltweiten
medikamentenstudie im kampf gegen das
virus vielversprechend für oberarzt
christoph spinner ist unter anderem ein
mittel namens fremde sie wir antiviral
wirksames arzneimittel dieser polymerase
hemmstoff rente sie wir trägt dazu bei
dass sich das virus nicht mehr vermehren
kann
eigentlich wurde das mittel einst gegen
ebola entwickelt doch die tests brachten
damals keine zufriedenstellenden
ergebnisse der wirkstoff wurde nie
zugelassen
nun rückt der im zusammenhang mit corona
wieder in den fokus jetzt gibt es
laborexperimente die große hoffnungen
wecken dass die antivirale potenz also
die wirksamkeit ausreichend groß ist
dass der erkrankungsverlauf auch im
menschen verkürzt wird und genau das ist
ziel der jetzt laufenden klinischen
studien herauszufinden ob fantasy wir
auch im menschen positive effekte auf
den erkrankungsverlauf mit sich bringt
beim praxistest konzentrieren sich
christoph spinne und sein team auf
mittelschwer bis schwer erkrankte
patienten
die teilnahme ist für sie völlig
freiwillig das bedeutet ein arzt
bespricht mit dem patienten den
individuellen erwarteten nutzen im
vergleich zum potenziellen risiko und
die menschen und hier unseren patienten
können dann freiwillige teilnahme
einwilligen ein teil der patienten
bekommt das medikament für fünf bis zehn
tage intravenös verabreicht ein anderer
teil wird wie herkömmlich ohne das
medikament behandelt anschließend wird
verglichen wie stark unterschiede in den
zu untersuchenden studien parametern
also zum beispiel länger der erkrankung
zeitpunkt der entlassung oder vielleicht
sogar sterblichkeit sicher unterscheiden
auch andere arzneimittel sind teil der
groß angelegten studie
wichtig ist dass die mittel möglichst
geringe nebenwirkungen haben und eine
hohe effektivität
wenn wir jetzt antivirale therapien
suchen dann müssen diese nicht nur in
der lage sein die virusvermehrung zu
hemmen sondern auch wirksam dazu
beitragen dass die erkrankungsdauer
verkürzt wird die sterblichkeit
reduziert wird und dabei haben wir große
hoffnungen für eine vielzahl an
antiviralen arzneimittel so auch fremde
sie wir die zeit drängt viele corona
patienten brauchen schnelle hilfe
doch selbst wenn ein wirkstoff gefunden
ist bleibt die hürde der zulassung
christoph spinne sieht darin nicht
unbedingt ein problem für arzneimittel
die eine besondere dringlichkeit haben
gibt es die möglichkeit der sogenannten
beschleunigten als ein mittel zu lassen
das bedeutet ist die europäische
arzneimittel zulassungsbehörde hier ein
deutlich beschleunigtes verfahren von
nur wenigen wochen ermöglichen kann
weltweit testen und forschen mediziner
wie christoph spinner weiter in der
hoffnung dass ein wirksames medikament
gegen das corona virus noch in diesem
jahr zur verfügung steht
die zwillinge eller und noah sind in der
30 schwangerschaftswoche zur welt
gekommen und damit frühchen
normalerweise ja kein problem aber seit
corona werden zum beispiel hausbesuche
der kinderkrankenschwester nur mit
sicherheitsabstand durchgeführt dazu
kommt die ständige angst denn die babys
haben atemaussetzer und hilfe von oma
und opa gibt es für die junge familie
natürlich momentan auch nicht aus besuch
mit schutzkleidung und mindestabstand
nur so traut sich kinderkrankenschwester
sabine magiera zu ihren schützlingen die
zwillinge ella und noah kamen zehn
wochen zu früh heute wird sich zeigen ob
sie die kritische phase überstanden
haben hatten auch atemprobleme und
deshalb sind beide natürlich auch
monitor versorgt und natürlich wenn dann
so ein monitor alarmiert und die wissen
wir sind in der korona zeit und wir
wissen das geht halt auch auf die lunge
dass die eltern da deutlich mehr angst
dann haben betreuung auf distanz für
alle ungewohnt ich bin verband heute ja
ich würde sagen das ist jetzt noch
schlafen da haben wir nochmal chance und
sie macht kurz in ruhe noch zu
unterhalten
heller und noah kamen in der 30
schwangerschaftswoche zur welt
normalerweise stellt das kein problem
dar
doch aktuell ist alles anders in
deutschland gibt es derzeit etwa 65.000
frühchen
sie sind gerade besonders gefährdet die
entscheidende frage heute hat sich die
atmung der babys so verbessert dass sie
nicht mehr vom monitor überwacht werden
müssen
ihr hattet jetzt den termin für die
monitor auswertung noch bei der l aber
leider einen aussetzung
die hat es einmal aufgehört zu atmen für
knapp 15 sekunden
ok also das heißt sobald du alarm hörst
wächst du sie quasi ohne guckst ob sie
noch arge besonders am anfang haben wir
natürlich sofort angeguckt bewegt sie
sich noch nie und dann kann das sein
dass sie aus dem reflex dann wieder grad
mit hat die monitore müssen vorerst
bleiben und die ständige angst die die
jungen eltern seit der geburt begleitet
doch jetzt kommt noch die sorge vor
einer ansteckung mit dem corona virus
hinzu denn papa uwe muss jeden tag zur
arbeit außerhalb schaden einfach alles
mitbringt einfach dann mache ich mir
schon gedanken werden die beiden so weit
das auffangen zu können geht es aber den
kindern auch auf die lunge oder oder
würde ist einfach so wegstecken dann
würden wir hier vielleicht liegen und
und wird schlecht gehen und die beiden
hätten gar nichts aber da wird es
einfach nicht wissen und das auch keiner
sagen kann ist da die angst auf jeden
fall da kann man ja mal super 5140 beim
heutigen hausbesuch müssen die eltern
alles selbst machen unter anweisung von
sabine das einmal von ihm weg gehen er
hängt mit dem beinchen bei genua und
falsches gesicht 5440 auf 5.520 neu
entwickeln sich altersgerecht das sind
endlich gute nachrichten
die braucht mama sabrina gerade sehr
denn die komplette isolation macht ihr
zu schaffen nicht mal die großeltern
dürfen noch kommen und sie unterstützen
sabrina ist ganz allein und ost können
nicht helfen einmal haben um an opfers
haben die beiden natürlich irgendwie
anstecken zu können und andersrum den
teil die omas und opas auch genau die
risikogruppe im moment so dann würde ich
nicht von euch verabschieden
ja ihr wüste wenn muss ist jederzeit
verabschiedung auf ungewisse zeit
krankenschwester sabine weiss nicht wann
sie die zwillinge das nächste mal sieht
momentan kann sich jeder termin
kurzfristig ändern
da hilft wie so oft in dieser zeit eine
videobotschaft vertreiben und mir ein
bisschen die zeit unserer rechtsexpertin
saar attacke beantwortet jetzt noch
weiter zuschauerfragen zum beispiel von
nadine kochems ist es zulässig dass
eltern wegen der schließung von schulen
und kindergärten ihren kompletten
jahresurlaub nehmen müssen das erstmal
ganz wichtig ein grundsatz zu verstehen
wie man seine kinder betreut ist
privatsache um nicht sache des
arbeitgebers das heißt wenn die kitas
und schulen jetzt geschlossen ist das
wie wenn gegen korona ist das wie wenn
die wegen lösen oder weil die erzieher
streiken geschlossen sind und dann bin
ich als elternteil verpflichtet mich um
die betreuung meiner kinder zu kümmern
wie ich das mache ist mir selbst
überlassen ob ich mir den jahresurlaub
nehmen ob ich unbezahlt
freizeitausgleich nehme
ob ich jemanden engagieren der sich
um die kinder kümmert dass es mir privat
selber überlassen
aber der arbeitgeber ist nicht
verpflichtet darauf rücksicht zu nehmen
er muss deshalb auch kein home office
anbieten ok agnes auch in mali fragt in
unserem betrieb werden alle die nicht im
home office arbeiten können in den
zwangsurlaub geschickt darf der
arbeitgeber dass das darf er nicht also
solange man seine arbeitskraft anbietet
muss der arbeitnehmer sie auch annehmen
und dafür auch bezahlt das heißt in
zwangsurlaub schicken darf er niemanden
er kann natürlich darum bitten dass man
home office macht oder er kann sich
darum kümmern dass man in kurzarbeit
geschickt wird aber in den zwangsurlaub
also verpflichtet zu werden jetzt erst
mal 20 30 tage urlaub zu nehmen
dazu kann niemand verpflichtet werden ok
martin kriegs fragte wohnen in einer
mietwohnung mit garten da spielen unsere
kinder mit den nachbarskindern deren
garten auch an unseren grenzt wird damit
die kontaktsperre aus juristischer sicht
verletzt
das kennen ganz viele eltern das
natürlich kinder sich bewegen
nachbarskinder sind da und da entsteht
ein kontakt der eigentlich nicht
entstehen sollte ganz wichtig bei diesen
regelungen ist es zu schauen wo nicht
weil es gibt deutschlandweit keine
einheitlichen regelung das heißt man
muss schauen was geht in meinem
bundesland was gilt in meiner stadt was
geht mit einer kommune
da sind die webseiten der jeweiligen
bundesländer ganz gute gibt es die
verordnung und es lohnt sich auch diese
verordnung sich mal auszudrucken und
durchzulesen das klingt immer so
abstrakt juristische verordnung zur
ausgangs beschränkung oder kontakt
beschränkung ist aber relativ konkret
ist wirklich dazu gemacht dass man die
auch lesen kann sind vier seiten relativ
knapp und dann weiß man wie man sich in
seinem garten in seinem umfeld verhalten
soll
grundsätzlich ist es natürlich so dass
man abstand halten soll deswegen haben
wir diese regelung und beim auslegen wie
verhalte ich mich richtig hilft
eigentlich so eine faustregel dass man
sich immer fragen was es eigentlich sinn
und zweck dieser ganzen auflagen sind
uns weg ist dass man abstand hält
sondern zweck ist es das nicht fünf
kinder miteinander spielen weil sich
dann natürlich dieses virus austauschen
kann deshalb grundsätzlich sollte man
das verhindern
trotzdem wird das praktisch natürlich
vorkommen bei kindern ist es ja auch ein
bisschen schwierig
jörg fragt wir haben ende mai urlaub an
der nordsee gebucht und auch schon
bezahlt bekommen wir das geld wieder
wenn wir nicht fahren dürfen wenn sie
nicht fahren dürfen dann ja also es
kommt wirklich darauf an wie ist die
situation ende mai aktuell geht die welt
weise weitere reisebeschränkungen bis
ende april
und dann muss man schauen ende mai darf
man da schon wieder an die nordsee oder
nicht wenn man nicht an die nordsee darf
dann ist es unmöglich da hin zu kommen
und dann habe ich einen anspruch darauf
dass mir das geld erstattet würden
aktuell die geltende rechtslage auch
völlig unstreitig aber auch da will die
bundesregierung ran und will verfügen
dass man bei pauschalreisen bei flügen
also bei allem was man im vorhinein
gebucht und bezahlt hat nicht mehr
keinen anspruch mehr darauf hat das geld
zurück zu bekommen sondern dass auch
hier die gutscheinlösung eingeführt
würde also es kann sein dass bis dahin
die rechtslage die geltende rechtslage
schon geändert wird das steht noch eine
zustimmung der eu kommission aus aber
wenn die kommen sollte kann es sein dass
für reisen ende meistens gilt dass man
nicht mehr das geld zurückbekommt
sondern stattdessen gutscheine für eine
reise im nächsten jahr an soll da die
entscheidungen ungefähr fallen weil von
der eu könnte ende dieser woche anfang
der woche kommen dann unterhalten wir
uns bestimmt noch mal drüber
roland fragt auf einer baustelle
arbeiten bis zu 40 personen
schutzmaßnahmen werden nicht eingehalten
ist das denn erlaubt natürlich nicht
erlaubt den schutzmaßnahmen nicht
eingehalten werden grundsätzlich muss
man sagen diese ganzen ausgangs
beschränkung kontakt beschränkung die
uns einschränken zielen vor allem auf
private ab sie zielen nicht so sehr aufs
berufliche ab was dazu führt dass es zb
untersagt ist dass drei personen privat
in der fahrgemeinschaft zu ihrem
arbeitgeber fahren dann aber dort von
ihrem arbeitgeber in ein auto gesetzt
werden können zu dritt um zur baustelle
zu fahren ja also das ist dieser
unterschied der absurd ist aber der da
gemacht wird
trotzdem hatten arbeitgeber natürlich
auch eine fürsorgepflicht für seine
arbeitnehmer und eine baustelle mit 40
personen ohne schutzmaßnahmen ist nicht
zulässig und es klar danke für die
information saar attacke sehr gerne
und unser corona kompakt das finden sie
auch auf youtube auf dem kanal der
heute.de wenn auch sie eine frage an
unseren experten haben dann schicken sie
uns eine mail an
corona kompakte zdf.de einige davon die
werden dann hier im studio beantwortet
morgen geht es darum was das virus mit
unserem kopf macht dann ist nämlich der
der psychotherapeut dr christian de
tritt zu gast